do you think do you feel the countries
in crisis probably why because nobody
seems to be able to decide on what they
wanted to do
do you have any confidence in Tereza
made that she can sort things out I feel
really sorry for Suri as my I think
she's in a no-win situation what happens
next
simple as that absolutely yeah because
that's the best deal or because that's
the easiest option or because that's
what I wanted I think you've all made a
mistake people made a mistake they based
their decision on lines it's all come
out now
and I think that I don't see how Teresa
may stay or last not perfect can be
worse than no deal so hopefully people
use a little bit of common sense vote to
leave still I'll probably still what
well folks we've again Fu K to a second
referendum do you feel the whole country
feels as if there's a bit of a crisis
now well I don't think we'd like to say
I don't think we know where we're coming
to going cuz nobody seems to know where
we stand what the deal is or is he and I
just can't wait for the 29th to March
which is when we supposedly come out and
thank you from there how much faith have
you got in Theresa May at this time
absolutely none whatsoever but there
again I won't pop - Jeremy Colby no one
trusts him as far as good throwing its
ambles but it was always going to be
with people lots of people pulling in
different directions
yeah is that Theresa made you still have
confidence in her yes of course I do
she's probably very much more
intelligent than I am and what in your
view needs to happen next because
there's lots of options on the table no
one can quite decide
I don't think there are options that's
where we go wrong we have too many ideas
and don't stick to one which is going to
be plausible and acceptable by the
majority of us